non merci à Julien
Julien Julien Julien Doré bien sûr vous
avez vous avez tourné dans Kiki des
clips c'est mon ami
sur la route pour venir chez vous j'ai
reçu un message de lui
je suis très poli qui me souhaiter c'est
bon veux 2022
donc voilà parce que j'ai plus entendu
sa voix depuis longtemps il est venu
nous voir et quelques temps c'est vrai
qu'est-ce qui vous a raconté le bouton à
gauche pour
ça que voilà
effacer par une gomme à mâcher est fixé
par une colle à sniffer
reporter sur tes pas cher sur ta robe
Chloé
je suis heureuse de cette amitié qui a
quand même quelques années je crois oui
je l'avais rencontré sur l'émission je
vais présenter
et
je comprends jamais les gens qui sont
d'autres personnes
départ qu'on commence à qui sont super
mais on peut tomber quoi ben il tombe
pas jamais de trouver son endroit de
vérité d'être passé je l'ai vu dans la
plainte de période différente et puis
c'est quelqu'un qui a
une gentillesse profonde enfin voilà